all right guys
bang bang i've got mike here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
yeah absolutely thanks for the invite
for sure let's uh let's jump right into
your background kind of tell us what did
you do
before you found crypto and then how did
you find bitcoin in cryptocurrencies
yeah so if we go all the way back i was
born and raised in rochester new york
and i think the other part in my early
beginning was my mom is from iceland
so she uh came to this country when she
was 18
and she left a family of 18. and
just recently i've been thinking about
how risky that was and i think
some of the risks i've taken throughout
my life probably come from
her as a an example of that um and then
i
went to my dad said you want to take
over the company and i'm like no i want
to go to college
and uh i went got a civil engineering
degree in mba at the university of
buffalo
and i got on ge's leadership program
where i was a six sigma black belt lean
manufacturing
and then essentially the last 10 years
of my career i spent
as a hired gun in the private equity
world so
kind of fixing companies uh so that's
you know
like quick quick background what's your
typical crypto background i guess
what are some of the biggest lessons
that you learned as a hired gun like
when you would go into these broken
companies what are some of the things
that uh we're kind of immediate we got
to fix this stuff
so one was um you know setting a clear
vision and
tapping into the kind of the passion of
the of the people
and then i think the other the other big
item was you know you gotta have the
right people in the right seats
so there's a lot of focus around talent
talent talent and then
um you know i'm a firm believer that if
if you get people that are excited about
their jobs they're gonna
they're gonna give it their all and you
give them some freedom and
they typically over deliver i
i tend to agree with that for sure how
did you first come across
cryptocurrencies
so the the first so
i would say um in 2000 i think it was
june of 2017
uh i was in between assignments and my
wife asked me to take the summer
off she's like just stop because i just
been going
you know like 20 years just not you know
crazy and
so we took the whole family to italy for
a family vacation i read a great book
homodaeus um by yuval harari i don't
know if you've
if you've read that or not but it's kind
of about the future of
how mankind and technology come together
and evolve
and literally we got home and i read an
article about blockchain i'm like wait
this is exactly what he's talking about
and it reminded me of the start of the
internet you know so i was in college
like when netscape came out like early
early early days
and you know the rally was i i kind of i
chickened out i should have moved to
silicon valley instead i kind of took
the safe route and went
to work at ge which was you know like
the big company at the time
and uh i just thought man this this
doesn't happen
this blockchain technology fixes a lot
of problems
and this doesn't happen very often in a
lifetime so i decided to
to explore it further and i basically
spent like 15 hours a day going down the
rabbit hole
i think my wife thought i was going to
be like serving her drinks out at the
pool
um instead i just sat up to my computer
all summer long and
and fell in love with crypto i started
trading it
and after about three weeks i realized
i'm not a really good trader
like too emotional and
uh and then i fell in love with the
mining space i thought wow you really
have to build out the infrastructure
first
before this thing's really gonna scale
and it just made sense to me like i just
it just seemed like that's the first
thing to go so i
literally poured everything i had into
it
and went full time you know and
i have to give a little shout out to my
my buddies in uh
buffalo because there was a buffalo
blockchain startup group
and i would drive out to buffalo every
tuesday to meet with these guys
and talk about a fish out of water like
these
these guys are they're software
programmers traders investors they knew
tons and i'm like the old guy in the
room with a notepad like writing down
everything they're saying just trying to
keep up
and it was like they're on twitter and
wechat and whatsapp and signal and
telegram and through these chat rooms
with thousands of people just saying
whatever they wanted and
it was really out of my element but um
i've come to
appreciate that that part of it so what
was the fascination or like what pulled
you
into the mining side of it all
like i said i think that it was you have
to build the infrastructure first
to to be able to scale and
i thought um i thought i can do that
right like i'm an engineer i understand
how to
to to be efficient at
plugging in machines and i just got i
could get my head wrapped around that
concept
more than like programming some
blockchain application
you know i part of it part of my journey
i thought you know at some point this is
gonna
this blockchain is gonna come back into
the traditional world
and since i spent most my career in the
traditional world i thought if i could
learn
this new kind of technology i could help
bridge that gap i still think we're
years and years away from it but
i think the easiest place for me to make
that leap was on the mining front for
sure
and maybe give us an overview where the
mining industry is today in terms of
um kind of how big is this who are the
players
and then maybe geography wise uh is
there
things going on in north america in asia
there's kind of so many rumors like how
do you
see mining as a business uh in an
industry
yeah maybe i can tell part of that story
as like how i
kind of grew up in my journey so i've
been in the space for three years
um got a chance to run a small company
here in western new york called
savage we grew it from like one megawatt
to three megawatts which
you know in late 17 early 18 seemed like
you know a monster
uh a monster location and then um i knew
the guys that started core scientific
and i went down to see what they were
doing and this is like
early 2018 and they had built out
like six megawatts in six weeks which
just kind of like
i was like whoa these guys are moving
fast and they talked me into joining
um them and helping them kind of grow
their business and over the next
year it scaled to 100 megawatts and then
um and then about a year ago barry
called and said hey
we're ready to get into the mining space
and would you like to come lead the team
so you know mining has
you know if you go back to the beginning
it was like any pc in the world you
could
mine bitcoin with right and then it
moved to gpus
and then it got to these very specific
computers
asics that really only do one thing but
mine bitcoin
and the scale just keeps growing faster
and faster and faster right so
um you know one megawatt was huge
four years ago and then 20 megawatts was
big three years ago
and now people are all talking about
building 50 and 100 megawatt facilities
um
so it's just it's moving the the space
moves so so quickly
yeah and so talk a little bit about dcg
and foundry right so
you get this call from barry he goes hey
we're gonna get into mining uh
they're not an average investor
or a team they've obviously made some
very very big plays and
been super successful with a lot of
things they've done
what was your reaction when you got that
phone call and then kind of what have
you guys done so far
yeah i mean i you know being on the
outside always looking in it was
it was like wow there's a lot of special
things happening at dcg so i was
and they they really avoided the mining
space
and uh you know the mining engine you
were a miner
right didn't you mine a little bit um in
the early days
it's a tough industry and it's like the
wild wild west
and there's a lot of interesting
characters
and everyone's got a story and you can't
tell what's real and what's not real
and you know when i sat down with barry
he basically said look at
this was my experience early in the
early days and i just didn't want
anything to do with it um and then he
goes
you know about a year and a half ago
they tried to buy some machines
you know not very many and he goes it
hasn't changed much and he just couldn't
believe
that the mining industry still operated
that way and he
he just thought now is the time for it
to kind of
let's up the game around mining and
uh he said he felt like it was the right
time to
to to bring in you know bigger capital
um you know to take so my job is really
like let's leverage the dcg
balance sheet let's leverage its brand
let's leverage its
its portfolio companies and how do we
create um solutions that can help
the mining industry in north america and
he really is like look
here's a blank sheet of paper tell me
what this industry
needs and where we can add the most
value and
it didn't take long before we we kind of
came to the conclusion that
we're getting ready to go through
another cycle there's new machines that
are coming out it's time for everybody
to upgrade
their equipment and they just there's
not enough capital
and what's interesting is you know most
of these machines are all
manufactured in china and the chinese
typically get the first
you know crack atom and you need out you
need to make those
you need to make big bets early in the
process to get to the head of the line
and we felt like this was the right time
to do it so
you know um back in january when nobody
really wanted to buy
machines we started making very big bets
on new equipment
um so that we could get to the head of
the line and that we could get our hands
on the machines
so um we so that's what we're doing
we're
we are helping miners in north america
um upgrade their facilities and uh you
know we mine ourselves
that's not you know it's not our goal is
to be the biggest miner that's not what
we're saying that
we're setting out to do what are really
our goal is to decentralize the hash
rate
around the world right like how do we
support these decentralized
infrastructures and and i should know
it's not just proof of work it's also
proof of stake right so we're
we've got a whole team doing um proof of
stake nodes
and supporting kind of that new industry
that's that's starting to develop
so talk to me a little bit about this
cycle um that you're talking about right
so
um there's the kind of the price cycle
but there's also
uh lead times on building out hardware i
think it was like nvidia and a couple of
other
folks who had gotten into um trying to
build
cards and and gpus and things like that
really got kind of
caught um in the wrong side of the cycle
in 2018 where
you know 17 they saw this big boom in
demand they came to market with
all kinds of hardware next thing you
know a lot of that demand had basically
dissipated by the time that they
actually got everything there
they had a bunch of inventory kind of on
their hands and they weren't able to
um you know offload it in the price
points and timing that they wanted
so maybe help people understand like
where we are today we're recording this
in october of 2020. how do you see
where we are now and the kind of what is
the expectation or like why did you
think that
2020 was the year to start something
like this
the cycles in the mining industry are
brutal
i don't know how else to say it um why
and i think
i think you have to have different
strategies for you know each part of the
cycle
um leo zhang had did a nice research
paper on this just recently and he kind
of talks about like the four cycles of
the mining space and um
part of it is like the bitcoin algorithm
is
like the most efficient thing on the
planet
and it's ruthless in terms of its desire
to keep driving
cost out so there's this this race
to get lower cost energy there's a race
to
build a stronger machine and we go
through these cycles because
when new technology comes out that is
you know
two or three times better or more
efficient than the prior generation
people who want to upgrade to that
equipment and what it does is it
forces as as we upgrade
it forces out the weak hands right so it
forces out the people with high
operating costs it focus
for forces out the people
that have older technology and
what happens is the bitcoin network just
gets bigger and stronger and more secure
each time this happens and so we go
through these cycles and they're
they tend to be you know 18 to 24 month
cycles sometimes you know a little bit
longer
and it really depends on how fast they
can innovate the
the chips so you have to understand
where we are in those cycles and which
machines to purchase
and it's interesting because you almost
have to bet counter cyclical
right so i don't think it's much
different than probably
you know exploring for natural gas or
oil
or like there's times to be investing in
the space and there's times to be
pulling
away and right now we
were very bullish on where this is going
we think that the
latest generation equipment is going to
be here for several years we think it's
a great time to
invest and when i tell people because i
get this i get asked this question all
the time
i'm like look at the minute all your
online calculators say it's
time to mine it's too late you you won't
be able to get the machines if you can
you're going to overpay for them
uh it's it's kind of you've got to be
able to make that bet
before that happens like you want the
machines
plugged in mining when this thing
goes up so we think it's a great time
right now
absolutely and then talk a little bit
about the process of actually upgrading
a facility so somebody's got a facility
they've got older equipment in there
they're mining uh there's revenue coming
in the door you guys go to them and kind
of how do you work with them what is
your
product suite or service suite look like
in terms of how you can actually help
that minor upgrade
yeah absolutely so we're um so we
created a product for
you using the equipment as collateral
which was something that really hadn't
been done in the space before
and we've deployed you know we've
deployed a hundred million dollars
into north american mining this year
um and so what we do is we allow miners
to
to get some leverage on on
you know they they typically don't have
a lot of cash sitting around right so
um we allow them to to get their new
machines plug them in
and then you know we take a monthly uh
you know
interest and principal payment we let
the machines pay for themselves you know
over the course of the next
you know 12 or 18 months we also provide
advisory services
so we help people um think through their
their business their um you know how to
avoid a lot of the
the traps that they're there is in
bitcoin mining like you really
you only have to make a couple missteps
and lose all your money you know so
i would say that if there's anybody
that's looking to deploy
a lot of money into mining call us first
we can kind of talk you through it you
know like
why this is either a good idea or a bad
idea and uh we can definitely
help help you find the right people in
the market so
like we don't have any of our own
facilities um so we
we've done a lot of due diligence to
find out who the best operators are in
north america
who who where the best costs are where
you can put your machines and feel good
about it
and then we have a very strong working
relationship with
micro bt and with bitmaid you know so
we talk to them daily and um
you know they're very excited about
growing the north american market
they see it as a is a huge opportunity
yeah
uh can you name any of the people that
you have kind of put a thumbs up on
in terms of minors in the us or do you
want to refrain from that
you know i was i was thinking about that
i'm sure they would all love me
to to name each one and then i'll
probably forget somebody and i'll get a
lot of trouble
um so we'll you know over the next
couple months i think we'll be
more and more vocal about who who um
we're working with um but there's a lot
of great operators in north america
and they've you know they spent the last
three years building out you know
large-scale mining
and north america everyone loves to talk
about the chinese and
and all the stuff they're doing with
with hashrate i would love
you know my goal is three years that
it's no longer a story line like we
don't talk about it anymore because the
hash rate is more
you know evenly spread out throughout
the world and north america has got a
ton of advantages i mean it's
we have a lot of power in this country
um and and in canada um
i think the temperatures are right the
infrastructure's there
and it's you know it's a lot of
abandoned power so we can
there's a lot of people they find these
spots they step in and
and and a lot of the local communities
are figuring this out
and they're embracing it they're like
wow this is a big deal you mentioned
power uh one of the things that everyone
loves to talk about
uh who does not like bitcoin is you
idiots are all spending all of the power
uh you're you literally consuming more
power than some countries
uh stop doing that this isn't
environmentally friendly uh
i think usually the most popular
response from
uh those who support bitcoin or are
intrigued by it is
yeah but most of its renewable power uh
kind of
how do you guys just see power
consumption
uh the sources the amount like just talk
me through
you know how you guys look at that or
any frameworks that you use to think
about it
yeah so it's great and a lot of people
um like to bring that up
so i think there's about eight gigawatts
worth of power right now
um securing the bitcoin network so
there's definitely an element like if
you believe in bitcoin
the more power that secures it the
better it is for the network and the
more
valuable the network is so um
and i think there's it's it's incredibly
transparent
how the how how much power is being used
right like
everybody in the world knows how much
power is being used for the bitcoin
network
how much power is being used to
run all of our banks you know every time
i turn around there's like a new bank
being built on a corner i'm like why are
they building banks right now it doesn't
this doesn't seem like
it makes a lot of sense or how much
energy does our
military use to secure our country
and the u.s dollar right like you you
were you're in the air for i think
you're in the air force right
army okay you're an army guy but the air
force spends like nine
billion dollars on fuel right we spend
two billion dollars on
electricity to secure the the bitcoin
network
um and i'd say the other piece is where
you know the with the the bitcoin
algorithm is so
ruthless in terms of driving cost out
that it's constantly looking for
low-cost
energy and what we're finding is there's
lots of pockets of this around the world
where it actually helps the grid it
helps the power grid it makes it more
efficient you know there's
there's peaker plants in new york the
greenwich guys are the
you know they're a great team there
where they're actually they've got an
on-site bitcoin mining facility and it
allows them to be more efficient to
power the grid
and it's like wow or my other favorite
is like new york you live in new york
i live in new york right we have an
abundance of hydro power
that just fl it just flows over the dam
and it's like guys
you could be making money off of that
right now
it's just going unused and they and they
can't get their head wrapped around it
yet
but we think that's changing very
quickly i mean i think in the future
um we've we believe very strongly that
the the electric companies the power
producers they're they're going to get
engaged in this industry
um that we're already starting to see it
uh and i think nation states at some
point are gonna
are gonna say oh wow we got to get a
bitcoin strategy
and we've got these natural resources
let's use it
to produce bitcoin people i don't think
like the fact that it's
iran but i think iran created a process
to license people to mine within the
country and even
put some of their national resources
not natural but national resources
towards doing it
it sounds like you think that maybe some
of the
more fringe locations we'll do it first
but actually we should see uh every
nation state eventually do this
i i think so i mean every nation state
has a strategy around oil
they have a strategy around natural gas
they have a strategy around gold and i
think they're gonna have a strategy
around bitcoin and i think part of that
strategy is
we can produce it we have a we have an
advantage
and we need to take advantage of you
know use that advantage to produce
bitcoin um i think it's just a matter of
time
like where where does this go it's it's
moving so fast that i think it's
inevitable that it's going to happen and
our goal at foundry is
you know when when that nation state is
ready to get into the space
you know we hope that they call us
because we've got the experience
and the trust to help them kind of
navigate through that
is there any specific inflection point
that you guys are looking at for say
like the u.s government
or other kind of global superpower that
would really push them or accelerate
them into doing this
um i don't know i think it's
it's kind of like once it starts it's
gonna be hard to stop
you know it's kind of like uh you know
some of the companies now that are
investing
in in uh their their treasury into
crypto
right it's i think all of a sudden it's
like wait they're doing what
and wait they're hot they're making how
much money on this and why are they
doing it and
why aren't we doing it you know and i
think it's just a matter of time before
every country is going to be asking that
that question
yeah you mentioned north america a
couple of times
and kind of the hash rate distribution
talk through a little bit of like where
are we from north american hash rate and
kind of
how you guys see that being important to
kind of continue to increase
uh on a global distribution basis
you know it's really hard to tell
exactly the distribution of hash rate
around the world but
some studies like the cambridge study i
think puts china over 60
um i think there i think there's a lot
more in the u.s than
than they've got in their calculations
but i think we're probably in the 10 to
15
range right now and i think over the
next
24 months it's probably gonna double
i think there's there's going to be more
and more capital flowing into
north american miners the facilities
have been built out there's some really
big projects that are going to be
announced soon
for additional capacity and i think you
know there's a
there's a limit of there's a limit at
the
wafer production uh facility so tsmc
and samsung they they can only give so
many wafers to the
basic manufacturers so there's only so
many machines available
and i think as long as we continue to to
buy those machines we're going to start
seeing the hash rate shift from
from china to north america and look i
don't think north america should
dominate
either i think it needs to be evenly
spread throughout the
world that's what makes bitcoin you know
great
absolutely what's the biggest risk that
you see to the mining business whether
it's here in north america or elsewhere
biggest risk
you know it's one of the most efficient
markets right so i was gonna my first
reaction was oh if bitcoin priced
tanks you know oh no but as you know
every
you know was it 2000 it's like 2 000
blocks or something like that every 14
days the difficulty readjusts
so it it self regulates and
you think about like the oil industry
you got a bunch of guys
sitting in a room deciding how much oil
they should pump out
or not and what are we going to do to
fix the price and
it doesn't have the algorithm besides
that you know and and everybody in the
world collectively mining kind of
decides that so
if bitcoin price tanked hash rate's
gonna tank difficulty is gonna tank
and then it'll make sense to mine again
right so
um so i don't know what the i don't see
any major risks right now i
suppose i suppose the u.s government
printing more and more money and we had
to
you know economic ruin that that would
be detrimental to
a lot of folks but and in terms
of how you guys see um kind of the
mining cycles
and some of those risks does it feel
like
there's just much more knowledge in the
market like that's what i'm kind of
pulling
here or i'm taking away from you is like
there's just so many more
experienced miners and people who have
kind of seen multiple cycles now and so
they feel like
um there's a better understanding of
some of the risks or potholes
you know kind of in the strategies but
also the market cycles and kind of what
to do
how to scale how to build up these
facilities that miners should be in a
better position
kind of moving forward through future
market cycles oh absolutely i mean i
think the industry is
it's maturing at this incredible pace
and it looks very different today than
it did a year ago
i mean today there's you know we're
financing equipment
manufacturers a year ago every miner in
north america was
begging for that solution and it didn't
look like anybody would ever
step up and do it um so it it's
it's changing quickly i mean we're even
you know we're looking at the
derivatives market right so like miners
i've always said like
miners are really good at making a
bitcoin and doing it really efficiently
but most of them are horrible at
treasury management i know i can speak
for myself like
i didn't know what to do and mine is
bitcoin and sometimes we'd sell it every
day and others was like no let's hold it
and let's try to time the market
and it was just a mess um so we're
working with like the genesis team
and we're selling um forward eric calls
um on you know future production
it's like wow we're we're actually
making we're making extra money doing
this and it's not hurting our operation
and it's a better way to manage our cash
flow and
it's like whoa this is really cool and
our our goal is how do we train and help
other
miners take advantage of that stuff so
that they can you know shore up their
operations and and be more profitable
yeah and it's one of these weird
businesses too right we're like what
other business does your balance sheet
expand
like the actual value of your balance
sheet can expand or shrink
at a very rapid rate right yeah it's
scary it can be very scary
and so really is it fair to say that
most miners are
one infrastructure investors right two
they have to
um drive the cash flow from the mining
activity but then three also
it's almost like they're uh traders or
um that treasury management you're
talking about like there's multiple
components to this business
and you've got to be pretty good if not
great at all of them to be successful
yeah i think you you sum it up very well
yeah
i mean i you know i think um i'm
starting to view
mining almost like um critical
infrastructure
you know so like almost like a utility
right so i think a lot of miners
i think they come into it with a little
bit of a wrong approach of we're gonna
you know get rich quick
and i've yet to meet any of those guys
you know so um i don't think it's a get
rich quick
kind of business you know kind of like a
utility is not a get rich quick
business i think mining is over time is
going to become a very
stable industry very predictable
it's going to you know kind of produce a
dividend
for its investors and i think if you
want to get rich quick
just go buy bitcoin yeah well nasty as
part of the
uh decision people have to make right is
do you want to just invest in the asset
itself
or if you go ahead and you invest in
mining the idea is that those machines
will generate more bitcoin over time
than you could buy right now with the
same dollar amount right um and that's a
calculation that to your point
really depends on price on market cycle
and the technology you buy the
the shelf life of that technology how
expensive is the power what's the source
of your power like
there's a lot a lot of inputs here and
if you're sophisticated and you know
what you're doing
it's great business to be in if uh if
you're not good luck
right yeah for sure
uh what has been some of your biggest
takeaways so you guys have invested 100
million dollars or so
uh into mining uh you've partnered up
with uh with dcg to do this what's been
kind of your biggest takeaways in 2020.
the world's been chaotic and and uh in
so many ways but kind of from a business
perspective
what's been the one or two surprises or
takeaways that you've had
so early in the year um
i think for me personally a couple
surprises is the like the i the dcg team
is amazing
right like i i for they're just a great
group of people i thoroughly enjoy
working there
they they have probably a better
better outlook or look into the you know
the whole blockchain space than anybody
else so
they really understand it and they
understand the risks and the rewards and
and uh barry's been really supportive
he's like look at mike you don't have to
hit home run just get on base like we
just need to get on base on
you know a regular you know cadence um
and and this idea of betting counter
cyclical i think is
is really really important so we placed
some really big bets early on
the micro bt guys they basically said
mike
get your machines installed help your
customers
um and you're gonna be just fine and
they've been right you know so
you know all the online calculators
would tell you that you know the payback
is 18 months for the new equipment it
was the same thing
in may and yet i've been mining with
equipment for six months and it's worth
the equipment's worth more today than
what i bought it at
and i've been mining for six months you
know it's like i think this is
actually going to hold true for quite
some time because we're early in the
cycle so
um i really encourage you know people if
you're
i i've told a lot of people like if you
if you don't think now is a good time to
get into the mining space
you should just buy bitcoin like if
you're struggling today
with this decision um then this isn't
the right
space for you one of the last things i
want to do before
before we get into some of the rapid
fire stuff is um
help people understand the unit
economics so
again a lot of these are variables that
will change depending on your location
your operations all this kind of stuff
but just
generally uh if somebody buys one
miner uh and they were to plug it in
kind of how do you guys look at
um you know the average cost on a power
side and then like what does that look
like over
let's say 24 months or something like
that in terms of
how much they can actually generate if
they do it the right way right so they
come to your advisory services
you guys you know kind of walk them
through here's what to do what does that
unit economics look like in kind of the
bold case
yeah so i think i think most miners want
their machines to pay back in less than
12 months right and when
when the industry gets really frothy or
when it did the last time it was like
machines were paying back in in three
months four months you know it was like
you plugged it in and you got all your
money back and it was amazing
i think one of the important things to
look at is how long do you think the
machines are gonna last
um and and how efficient are the
machines
that you're buying because that's gonna
extend their life cycle right so
we're we we believe that these current
generation machines will last
three probably four years so you kind of
have to look at that overall
time frame and and part of this
is look at you could buy you could buy
bitcoin at a high price and the market
could fall
but while it falls you're losing money
if you just bought the coin
if you're mining you're still making
money through that whole process
right so the machines are still paying
for themselves so it's a little bit of a
hedge for the downside
um and then you you kind of get all the
upside if you get them plugged in before
before the market really runs um so you
got to buy them i still do you got to
buy them at the right price
you have to pick up a provider that
can get them installed when they arrive
and you got to have a low hosting cost
and that those
hosting costs continue to drift down and
then
you know have it have somebody that you
really trust in terms of
of running the machines for you because
they've got to be up and running all the
time
yeah makes sense what does success look
like for foundry if you look out
10 15 years from now what exactly are
you guys doing and you're like you know
what we did exactly what we wanted to
yeah so uh when i started barry said
look at that
i want you to build a business for the
next 10 to 20 years right like
everybody looks so short term in this
industry it's this is
this is for the long haul and i think 10
years from now
i i really do think nation states will
be
in the mining business somehow some way
and i think
uh will be their first phone call to
help them through that process
uh i also think that you know we didn't
spend much time talking about but the
proof of stake
world i think is going to be fascinating
over the next uh
five to ten years um it's still early on
but you know these teams have been heads
down
building for the last three years you
know even like today's a big day
filecoin launched right like they've
been working on this thing for
three plus years and it just went live
today and there's so many
other proof-of-stake protocols out there
that are going live
that the teams have been working for
years on and i just think that's gonna
it's gonna be really interesting to see
how that all all plays out
absolutely i always ask the same two
questions to everyone before i
uh i finish up uh first is most
important book what do you got for me
yeah so um
so most important book i would you know
i think there's different books at
different
parts of times in my life that have been
like the most important book
um i'll tell you when i was a young kid
i really struggled to read
um so when like early grade school
that's probably why i became an engineer
because i wasn't good at
reading and writing and um
so now i love to read you know like now
i just can't i can't take enough of it
in but
you know probably the most impactful
book for me was a book called
a grace given um by
by a guy named kent gilgus and uh
it's about a father's journey in losing
their their his daughter and uh
in 2007 my four-year-old passed away
she had a bad heart and it was a really
really tough time and you know obviously
in my life
and i got a chance to meet the author
and read the book and it was like wow
here's somebody who was having the exact
same you know crazy thoughts i was
having and
it really it really helped me to know
that i wasn't alone
you know in this journey and it really
you know um
it was it was a huge just a big impact
for me so
highly recommend it it's it's um
you know it's a sad book but it's uh
also very
hopeful book and uh and we've been
blessed that
we were blessed to have another child so
um
it's been uh it's been quite the journey
yeah that does
that's uh it's always um the timing at
which you read books is almost as
important as
uh the actual book that you read right
and that's something absolutely
over all of these episodes uh has come
out over and over and over again so uh
such a great recommendation
uh the second one is a little bit more
fun aliens believer or non-believer
uh yeah i'm a believer you know like the
math just
seems to be there i was thinking about
this like
we only discovered gravity like 350
years ago like there's
500 years ago people still thought the
earth was flat like
we know so little about
about our own world let alone the
universe that i just think there's so
much more to
to be discovered i mean even bitcoin
bitcoin's only been here for 10 years
you know like very true very very true
um do you believe that we're in a
simulation
or are you just sticking with the alien
stuff
oh i was that bad i wasn't prepared for
that question
um yeah i love that you know those
things are always fun to think about
right like somebody came back and
satoshi came from the future and you
know i don't know if we go that far on
that one
or you know like uh you know like the
machines i love the fact that we're
building
we're building a computer that can never
be shut down
and and and the computer is
incentivizing us to go
do it and we are totally hook line
syncer we are
all in and trying to build this thing as
fast as we possibly can
you know transferring value is just one
level on what's gonna
what this thing's gonna be able to do um
so yeah it's kind of it's kind of crazy
i i tend to think it is uh absolutely
wild that we found ourselves in this
situation but i'm glad to be alive right
now
what uh what one question you got for me
to finish up
so i don't know people have asked you
like 400 questions or something so it's
hard to
and this one's probably been asked in
the past but um
what do you think is the biggest threat
to bitcoin
besides government takeover
or you know 51 attack or
self-inflicted wound like somebody
introduces code
that ends up having a bug in it i think
that's by far
like that's the most likely thing to
happen right i don't think that it is
likely to happen
but the thing that is has the highest
chance of happening
is that even more so than governments or
any of the other things that people love
to kind of talk about
um but it's still such a such a small
uh you know chance that that would even
happen um which
also speaks to like how unlikely it is
that a government is able to shut down
the bitcoin network
or a 51 attack happens or anything like
that
um so self-inflicted wound definitely is
one uh and then two is
um you know somewhat tangentially
related like it just takes time from
like a branding and marketing standpoint
like people you know i used to joke i'd
walk into uh
institutions and meet with their
investment committees
or their investment teams like oh this
sounds awesome where can we learn more
and like what am i going to be like
well you can go follow cryptopanda on
twitter like no
right like and by the way like that's
not a knock against a suit anonymous
account right of any of any of them like
actually that's where most of the best
information
right or like oh you should go to this
telegram
channel they're like what the hell's
telegram right so so it's like by the
way that's where the best information is
so i think that like it's just it takes
time to kind of build out all of the
infrastructure
and kind of sophistication that they're
used to to make them comfortable with
uh understanding it um and we're getting
there but you know it just takes time to
do this stuff
yeah people ask me all the time like can
you explain bitcoin or blockchain and
i'm like look at you you can watch
netflix on your phone do you
have any idea how that technically works
like do you know the difference between
tcp and ip and
like no so don't worry about it you know
just
just police what's the uh satoshi line
like uh
if you don't if you don't believe in
bitcoin i don't have time to explain it
to you or something
that's crazy um all right mike listen
thank you so much for doing this where
can uh where can people find you
and more about foundry on the internet
uh foundrydigital.com is um
i think the best place to get us um
twitter handle for me is
call your mic um twitter handle for
foundry is foundry services so yeah
we're
we're looking forward to uh the next 12
months i think it's gonna be a great
exciting ride i i tend to agree
and uh i don't think anyone believes
that you or i have any other opinion
than what we have so
that's right i'm sure on the table let's
see what happens
that's exactly yes we've placed our back
exactly all right mike listen thank you
so much for doing this we'll definitely
have to do it again in the future
yeah thanks bob i'll see ya bye